from hacksaw ridge and silence to jim
baker and under the banner of heaven you
seem drawn to portrayals of men who are
defined by their faith or loss of it uh
what draws you to these roles
that is a good question twitter user um
i it's i i don't know it's mysterious
isn't it we are drawn to what we're
drawn to and we love what we love
so
for me i'm i guess i'm i have this
endless curiosity towards
you know the spiritual dimension of
being alive like i
you know the fact that we're all gonna
die like that fascinates me and
how do we get ready for that because
it's coming
um and uh that that's what spirituality
is for me i think it's a kind of an
awareness of the finite nature of being
here
and making sense and meaning out of it
while we are here and where do the main
you know world religions get it right
where do they go astray and
and uh you know obviously in this film
there's a lot of going astray there's a
lot of um delusion and uh kind of
a misinterpretation of the gospel of
christianity specifically we're talking
about here so yeah i mean i i i don't
know i just for me it's it's a very
fertile ground that is endlessly
interesting because it's really
if you're dealing in that if you're
dealing with spirituality you're dealing
with faith and you're really dealing
with life and death and what what's more
vital what's what's the greater question
what's it camus said camus said the only
real important philosophical question
one can ask is should i kill myself
today or not it's like like you know
it's like and it's like what what and
what that but that question brings
meaning it's like well if i'm not gonna
kill myself today then then then i
better be here for a reason i better
enjoy the day i better do something that
feels good in my soul i better
you know you know so i i think that life
and death is is everything and that's
what spirituality is to me
i have so many follow-ups to that but i
gotta ask another question my god i have
so many follow-ups so i i listen i'm a
huge fan of your work and i think that
you bring this emotional honesty to the
screen when i see it um so i am curious
when you're getting ready to do
a dramatic or an emotional role an
emotional performance on say a monday
like it's going to really take a lot out
of you on a movie how are you getting
ready for that moment in advance are you
like days in advance breaking down what
i'm going to do is it the day before um
and maybe i'm just curious about how you
get ready as an actor yeah i mean it's
really interesting it changes every time
like i'm thinking about this particular
film and i think for me like i like to
go one day at a time i try not to get
too ahead of them i don't like to plan
anything i i prep i prepare in the sense
of like you know when you're making a a
long
like slow
boiling stew you're adding ingredients
over the like for in terms of preparing
you're adding just ingredients over
months and months and you put in some
carrots and you put in the garlic and
you put in
the spices and then you stir and you let
it heat for a bit you turn it down you
let it simmer and so then hopefully by
the time you start filming the the the
pot is full of all the flavors and then
you can just show up on set and
especially when you're working with an
actor like jessica or vincent d'onofrio
or cherry jones you just kind of like
you're in the scene you're present and
then your
every take is different you're not
knowing where the scene might go it
might be incredibly emotional in one
take and this in the next take it might
be cold or it might be
uh
something else might you just you'll you
allow yourself to follow the impulses
and that's the beauty of filmmaking and
you can do it on stages it's it's it's
more challenging to do and
nightly on stage but um but i think to
keep it alive to keep because if you rep
if you're repeating yourself and you're
and you're
you're doing the same action over and
over and over again
it starts to become false just by the
nature of if something worked in the
take before you you don't want to try
and replicate it in the next one you're
only going to create a false
um carbon copy of something that
previously worked so you're trying to
just stay alive and present to the
moment all the time
i have to stop there i'm just going to
say sir it's always a pleasure to talk
with you and you guys did such great
work in this for real nice to see you
dude appreciate it
you